Distributed query is securely
obtaining useful data
from diverse EHR systems and
other sources.
We'll look at three current open
source distributed query technologies.
They're different in their
technical approach and goals, and
understanding those differences and
the reasons for them is a key objective.
This overall effort is now under the ONC
supported Query Health Initiative.
I recommend you view an ONC video
referenced in the instructor's notes for
more details on the overall effort and
the individual systems
that comprised it.
As we learned in the interview
with Wellcentive,
there are also commercial
solutions to this problem, but
those are proprietary and less
available for this kind of discussion.